whoa Zack your best friend got killed
what are you gonna do oh hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
hotline miami a not new game in any way
shape or form but it's something of a
lot of people wanting me to play so here
I am playing it I'm here to tell you how
to kill people
why thank you sir how are you doing
today with the snot running out of your
nose in your yellow yellow teeth I guess
you're the best guy to give me the
advice this game is controlled with the
WASD keys in the mouse press the left
button about to punch and something to
kick once you've knocked someone out you
have to finish them to do this you press
space goddess are you sure left mouse
button to punch manage I gotta do you
understand me don't mess with up prod
because I will die come here yo gotta
finish my oh my all right now you should
try killing next guy let me know why I
don't know best to use Matt in the red
room over there press the right mouse
button next to it and taken okay did you
get that there here's y'all hey tell me
this is bad on you young man right nice
to pick up that's a swing Thank You Jon
so let's get the guns shall we
you go and get the shotgun in the Blue
Room you do it the same way you picked
up the bat just bro the right mouse
button can you handle that I got I got I
got shift button to looking for enemies
out of the view very useful you're not
getting yourself killed
okay press coil to lock on enemies I
actually read the instruction beforehand
so I know all of this stuff maybe I
don't know oh you have to look all right
so that's about sums up the basics
however there's always more tricks to
learn you can throw away any what you
pick up by holding the right mouse
button I notice I did it a home in okay
so this game it's a very stylized blah
blah blah if you like blood guts and
destruction and shooting enemies until
they explode in all sorts of flavors
you're probably gonna like this game
very much and what do we have here oh
you don't even know who you are
well maybe we should leave it that way
but I know you look at my face we've met
before haven't we
I don't know you
you hear you know just mine knowing
oneself means acknowledging one's
actions as it lately you've done some
terrible things I'll give you a clue to
see bro the third mean anything to you
no I believe that was the day of our
first encounter you look like you might
be remembering something yes indeed I
remember when I woke up in a stupor in
my craptastic apartment and then I
started murdering people randomly those
were the days anyway so I'm you have one
new message
hi this is Tim at the bakery the cookie
said your dad should be you've delivered
by now list of ingredients are included
make sure you read them carefully okay
No the target is a briefcase discretion
is of the essence leave target appoint
f30 tool inside the dumpster failures
not all of you will be watching you all
goody goody gumdrops so I knew a hotline
Miami is a game that came out about a
year ago little more than a year ago I
think by now but it was always meant to
be this bloody super ecstatic violent
game of extraordinary passion so I
intend to do it with my best ability
possible and now I'm richer than hi hi
you [ __ ] you wanna give me my money
what am i doing why am i holding what
about holding his head to my crotch ah
get it okay so anyway I gets bad time to
get this done
how you gonna I died I may not have
mentioned that this game is actually
quite difficult hey give me that
take that finish you up a space bum and
you're done son ah so if you gotta not
easy stomach you're gonna have a tough
time with it
I got a knife now you're all gonna get
it you're gonna get it now what do you
think you're ready for me he's ain't
crazy oh I thought I was gonna get to
that time but you got paperwork as you
you're done son you're done y'all done
you didn't see nothin your friend just
got killed what are you okay sorry I
didn't mean to do that I'm just gonna
scream randomly from over here oh I'm
ready let's do this
I got him that was not that hard that's
what she said and then you son of a
[ __ ] yeah this game is actually quite
difficult to UM and have a tough time
you're acting psycho
you wanna get stabbed
[Music]
you don't know I know I'm a man on the
edge you don't want to mess with me I'm
a terribly crazy [ __ ] head I don't know
if I was supposed to kill that guy but
he's very very very dead no no no I got
a briefcase I gotta go to the car
except I gotta to sir boy what are we in
Los Angeles no we're in Miami oh it was
a train well that doesn't seem very good
for my survival away one of us fault at
all oh wait a minute wait a minute oh I
can't go that way
oh you came out of nowhere except he
came out of exactly over there I knew
where exactly it was coming from but
somehow I still got killed by him oh you
didn't see nothing
all my brains could you please pick up
my brains for me please who's very
inconvenient of you to stab them out of
my face
I will get you you sons of [ __ ] angel
I call my mommy on you so what am I
supposed to do how am I supposed to kill
my oh that really oh my god oh oh my
head my head entirely came off that's
not good I didn't know that I was
supposed to whack him with a briefcase
if I knew I was supposed to whack him I
would've whacked him much earlier than
that oh god he's gonna get back up yeah
pissing balls yeah yeah dick you're
gonna mess with me that's right
destroyed then I've got another
briefcase with your name on it actually
it says Stanley Worthington whoever I
just stole this from whoever listen to
spag that I bashed the chest out of him
and stole his briefcase that's exactly
who it was
hey do you think that you could mess
with me someone over there is anyone
want a piece is a crazy kak that's my
day because I gotta check out my head
have the crazy yeah who's there I can
hear you oh yeah hey you're the guy that
taught me how to kill oh you're gonna do
now you ain't got nobody got nobody
[Music]
oh that guy who taught you how to kill
in the future he's never ever ever oh
god why did I do that why did I do that
why what why did I do that
okay bye everybody yay I've really never
played this game before and I've never
actually seen it so this is honestly the
first time
I've ever played this game and only crap
isn't it awesome
oh god brutal violence aside while blue
brutal violence included that is kind of
fun this is a fun game I love it
I'm actually playing this more later
maybe not for a video but I mean I may
play it in the future
Rasmus okay where am I now
ooh all that music hello oh you're not a
lady I thought you might have been hi
there haven't you seen you around
thought something might have happened to
you you seem really down over losing
your girlfriend I thought you said you
didn't know me don't remember seeing you
after that maybe we should talk about
something else
so out for a midnight snack huh I don't
worry about it's on the house good to
see you have a good have a nice night
thank you sir I'll grab some beers in
let me dice Nick I just play with the
door dongle food a little bit and then
be on my way
I love the style of the game too
top-down pixelated but still that
doesn't mean that it's bad wait a minute
why WA sighs the chicken ed guy if I was
the original guy who had a pig head on I
thought I had a pig head abundantly hey
we appreciate us Jews of course American
is cool it must be some together minus
50 blessings minus 50 I do to deserve
minus 50 blessings you have one new
message beep right away got a few kids
that need to be disciplined here I'm
only seven straight they see you have a
long talk with them orally nice to get
through these Rascals and not last son
be discreet
okay thanks Linda thank you baby I'll
see ya Bob no problem
also why did I kill the people that were
in the bottom floor of my house oh no
wait that wasn't everybody I thought
that was me about it apparently it
wasn't first Java no talk variation is
rewardin I'll go with Ozma's Rasmus
otherwise group
oh I like the music in this game is very
elegant in a way I do appreciate a game
with a good soundtrack I mean if it
can't be graphically expertise let me
sit on your chest for a little bit I'm
gonna pick up this back don't even think
about it cuz that means I couldn't get
to you and now I got your weapon I'm not
cute all your friends with them shotgun
now oh what's that oh look
happy birthday celebration delivery
smokey bam bam boom it's your buddy
gonna come through here somebody want to
say hi to me somebody wanna see a hi how
you doing good you don't go it good good
good Bob you deserve that for some
reason I think you deserve that
come on hello goodbye goodbye you missed
Mitch yeah come on oh oh god I'm so bad
games yes hello sorry special delivery
for you
what damn door I don't know how to do
that but I'm gonna sit on your chest for
a little bit
thank goal hope you enjoyed that as much
as I did oh I didn't even pick up the
gun that's okay
didn't eat it apparently just gonna do
this all by my hands done oh god [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass I am so angry with myself
but not with you guys you guys are
probably already angry with me because
I'm taking forever just to complete this
one you're on son
you didn't see a friend get killed there
oh no well that's you saying I'm bad at
games saying about bad at games well
that just makes me angry oh what's that
you heard something over there yes what
a flies oh what's that your brains are
all the way on the other side of the
room that's what I was supposed to do
and that's what I definitely did the
entire time that I was playing this game
I definitely remember how to play the
game correctly alright so anyway I need
to teach these guys a lesson
well that'll be a lesson that you'll
remember for all lifetime hope you boys
had a good time with that and I
certainly did myself you really though I
should learn to throw things at people
man I can't believe I did that whole
game on the first try or Brown chapter
whatever you want to call it animal I
don't know what's going ok come on come
on come on new mask I love Tony I love
him already I want to play with him
forever and ever and ever
hello hello welcome
oh you don't eat order you peeps already
done had a feeling you were on your way
here here let's just leave it at that
for now shall we
don't worry about pain it's on the house
cool thanks goodbye did I just pick up
my payment is that what I just got is
that actually my payment for my
babysitting for my teaching those little
kids a lesson so interesting yeah
you have one new miss peep this is
Thomas from the methadone clinic we've
scheduled a short meeting for you
tonight we're at North weather under
native or dream apartment 105 don't
worry we know this regimen is important
to our clients Thanks definitely doesn't
sound like I'm about to be set up and
murdered but I'll take it none the less
scuse me pardon me just going to my car
don't be afraid of dying I don't know
what you're talking about I've been
through this whole game I've never died
once what are you talking about game
[Music]
Pizza fury I liked Rasmus hello are you
sitting there that's good for you yeah
thank you I'll take that hot ok thank
you thank you
Wow oh you got me I thought I was gonna
make it oh wait oh you're dead
sorry my mistake I know how that can be
easily problematic for some people
oh I think I'll take that that is good
oh I think I'll take that that's about
to be even better it's alive but not
this time not this time buddy I got my
trusty shotgun I'm gonna buy some tables
brains and oh oh it's at your dad oh no
oh no you're all dead you're all dead
oh you saw goddamnit I didn't even see
me blend it in with the environment
it's not fair Bob ow ski hello goodbye
sorry I'm gonna leave now bye bye
everybody
Oh No Oh No good things got well now
well now well now I can't sit on your
chest apparently ha just thank you no
one noticed that door swinging Oh what
was that
so strange what I should probably go and
not cover the door oh oh if I should
have used a human shield of something I
got you both what are you gonna do son
Oh God
no you do not you gonna come through the
door there
hey Fred's gone kimochi I like this game
Oh an orange one why is it orange I
can't pick it up or is this douche miss
all right who else awesome you guys
wanna taste gets a little taste of
Rasmus what the hell happened over there
Jesus is that a dead body
oh my god so mutilated look what's that
oh did you do this to my friend Joey
look honest okay never mind I'm so sorry
I did not mean to interrupt your
playtime I'm just gonna go over here now
like my friend Joey but I think I have
to kill you so I'm not gonna risk the
whole operation and I'm gonna go get
this gun I'm gonna come back I'm gonna
teach you a lesson
okay cool Bobo's Thank You Chuck I
really thought I might have actually
screwed that one up there Earl
you um gross disgusting how about no
hello no I thought these guys a lesson
and I'm outie I'm outing 3,000 pasty
skins really fun I can't I can't deny
the fun-ness of this game guys it is
absolutely honestly really fun and I
mean be sucking it up but I just started
so give me a break
I think I'm doing okay I think I'm doing
quite okay c is for average c is for
[Music]
we're not gonna talk about what c is for
what did I get
whoa piggy piggy oh I also got Earl
apparently did our old die
hey I like that I like that a lot I want
to use that can I have that for the next
one little VHS ballots I wonder if his
same guy oh look at that hey dude good
to see you again did you hear about the
massacre the other night a bunch of
Russkies I heard no loss if he asked me
they say some maniac wearing a rubber
mask did it sounds like a seed straight
from a slasher this ha have a perfect
film for you one on the desk
take it it's on the house enjoy yourself
dude thank you thank you for the payment
for my murders I'm gonna play one more
mission guys because I'm actually having
a ton of fun here I don't want to stop
so I'm gonna play one more time come on
what game have you got for me now it's
came from hotline Miami's dating service
who have set up a date for you this
evening
she'll be waiting for your tablets or at
53rd place as usual make sure you wear
something fancy and discretion is very
important apparently not so anyway no
seriously I'm having a ton of fun guys
like I already know that this game has
been out for a while but still I'm gonna
recommend it I'm gonna give you the mark
of our stamp of approval here pay
attention to details let's see what else
I got here more guns where's Earl where
the hell is Earl
that is a lot of masks survive two
bullets well that'll be useful for me so
I'll take it
hello Earl wants to know are you guys
satisfied with your I thought I could
survive two bullets but apparently not
no get out of here don't even think that
you can be me no I throw again it's like
I'm like okay okay
Oh all over the floor you sure you're
okay thank you very much very powerful I
finally did it after one try I am a
genius at this game I am just so good oh
there's another floor good fun today
boom
having very much fun thank you
I'm so scared Oh God crazy mad craziness
what is this insanity over here what
fresh hell is this no one saw anything
no one suspected a thing when I murdered
everyone in the entire building well
with that goodbye sir good boy good boy
thank you thank you one at all thank you
one and all for this amazingly perfect
run oh goodness
you seem to be drooling a little bit
there sir what are you gonna do what the
hell do you think you're gonna do okay
I'm now oh that didn't work it's not
that is he I used every week that's
right all right oh these guys might be a
little tough might be just a little
tough
Oh bollocks
oh hey doesn't look happy about that oh
my god oh god please don't know what we
do ha I did not mean to do that
oh god that's horrifying I am sorry sir
you could have just stayed in your room
though hello are you dead from drug
overdose I know many things about drug
overdose and you look like you've been
drug overdose oh yeah oh I thought you
were dead um okay please don't tell me I
kill you okay good good this is better
this is the better option of the two
this is the ideal outcome so thank you
thank you for the alright alright don't
team go go team go team go
good job good job team I'm sweating I
remember I'm literally sweating all over
the place that was amazingly fun I'm not
gonna play anymore after this but God
dang that was so much fun that does not
look like the more the horror games that
I know oh hello yes something special
sweet sour how about an amaretto sour my
friend oh wait a minute what am i doing
alright this guy doesn't look so good
okay thank you thank you sir I'll just
be on my way now
have a good night probably gonna have to
get these dollar bills out of this drink
here but thank you thank you damn money
is better than none
whoa yay Oh No
what's going on hello where am I
what happened oh it's you again what's
have you've been busy since last we met
I see you remember me now don't you but
you still don't know who I am
you don't even know enter into the snus
why did you come back here you're not a
nice man are you you make me sick a
picture is starting to take form here I
wonder if it's accurate
some pieces don't quite seem to fit I
just don't like the way it looks I think
that time is up but we shall meet again
here you go here's four questions to
ponder number one do you like hurting
people I'm a tool who are leaving the
messages on your answering machine
number three where are you right now
find a question why are we having this
conversation that's all for now see you
soon I'm imagining that maybe these
scenarios are all in my mind and I
actually don't know why the hell I'm
doing these except I'm insane anyway
that's all I'm gonna play of hotline
Miami this game is amazingly fun by now
you've probably all played it but it is
my first time so hope you all enjoyed it
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching leave a like down below if you
enjoyed this video and as always I will
se you in the next video bye
[Music]
there we are